my first time
i can't believe how incredibly nervous i
am
what can possibly go wrong
it's kind of funny the kind of things we
get nervous about in this world it's uh
as if we're not hurling through space at
some incredible speed as if something
actually matters well okay
here i am talking to myself alone in a
room and i feel naked before a large
audience
so first time just uh living up to the
new year's resolution of uh having a bit
more fun
and i guess this is what uh one version
of fun looks like okay i did a
the chat is going nuts i'm not
um going to uh be able to at all pay
attention but there's an amazing team of
folks that i'm now working with that are
helping me out i mean they inspire me
every day i love i love working with
those guys and they're
monitoring the chats for questions
um
as if i can do a good job of answering
any of them still nervous okay so i did
a podcast conversation with you on
a few days ago if you haven't got a
chance to watch it please do i thought i
would do this kind of uh
live stream to answer any questions that
folks have
hopefully the audio's okay
if it's not i don't know what we're
gonna do i'll figure this out
okay
and uh
i'll probably do these kinds of live
streams on occasion try to keep them
short
try to have a bit of fun answer whatever
questions if you have questions about
the elon musk conversation i'd love to
answer them now
and maybe i'll do a quick recap first
before i answer questions
and if you
uh if you who uh
donate like super chats or whatever the
heck those are called please don't
donate a lot of money
the uh
let's say nothing more than 42 dollars
let's let's set the limit there i don't
need the money um i got so much love
from you guys i really appreciate the
support it's all
i can't i'm forever grateful and really
humbled by that
okay
let's see so one thing maybe get the
news out of the way even after the
conversation is uh the deliveries so
we've been going through a couple of
years
of obviously uh a turmoil and uh i would
even say suffering economic and
otherwise and one of the incredible
things is on the supply chain despite
all those challenges that uh
tesla and elon were still able to
deliver in large number of vehicles i
don't these days
pay as close of attention as i used to
in terms of the deliveries because i
used to be fascinated by sort of the
number of semi-autonomous robots that
are out there
the hundreds of thousands which is still
incredible to me so i think they were
able to set another record with
308
000 vehicles delivered in quarter four
of um
this year
making that a total of almost a million
vehicles for this year
936 000
so
936 000 vehicles delivered by tesla i
missed all the supply chain difficulties
amongst all the growth they're going
through amongst all the doubters
i think you'll listen to the podcast and
uh
you can you can listen to what elon says
about the dollars includes the letters
fck
that and you can fill in the blank
anyway um on the conversation itself
there's so much i could say maybe people
have questions specifically to that i
just want to kind of comment on
as a human being as an interviewer as a
researcher and a fan of the ideas in the
field of artificial intelligence i took
a lot away from that conversation was
really inspiring
one of the things is um
the real gift that elon gave me
of
i would say trust and friendship
in
just sitting there
and thinking so the silence to me was
um really powerful that he would trust
me that i wouldn't interrupt him that i
would just sit there and really listen
and then he could sit there we could sit
there in silence and think i think
silence is one of the most intimate
things that two people can share with
each other because
it's having a trust that like you're on
the same page
like with friends
with in relationships just silence can
be beautiful and uh in a podcast
conversation especially
when there's nerves where there's so
much uncertainty the mics are recording
uh silence is a real gift and it's a i
don't know like i said trust and
friendship
and also it made me realize as a fan of
podcasts how much i love the silence i
used to think
actually the first time we talked i
asked them
what one question would you ask for an
agi system an artificial general
intelligence system
and so he took a long time to answer
that that's so we got more comfortable
through the span of that conversation
and i actually one of the only things i
edited in that conversation was the
length of the pause actually made it
shorter than it was
and uh later i realized that
that's not you don't you don't need to
people couldn't wait
it's okay if the pause is 15 seconds
it's good to see a man
a human being think
and um that's one of the beautiful
things about long form
is you have as
much time as you need to think
oh do i click on these super chats let
me wrap up let me just finish
talking about a couple of thoughts i had
about that interview
so the other thing is
offline and on mic we talked a lot we
talked a lot offline actually
and uh
he sung praises to the engineers and uh
that the engineers
especially like the low-level uh
software engineers are the as he said in
the podcast unsung heroes
and uh they are to me too the people
that
make the compute infrastructure happen
the admins the devops people uh when i
worked at google that was the case too
yes the the machine learning stuff is
the sexy stuff that's what i worked on
but the people that actually do the
distributed compute they're able to uh
train the networks across a large number
of computers they're able to even just
like the low-level stuff even the
security stuff everything the whole
thing low-level
uh low-level software engineering uh
building a compiler from scratch so
doing the on
on board so on vehicle computation
making that efficient
making that uh reliable because it's a
safety critical system so that's that's
incredibly difficult and that's machine
learning is
in that situation honestly is the icing
on the cake it's the cherry on the cake
the the bulk of the work and the
incredible uh work that's being done is
on the low-level software engineers so
he sung praises to them and even just
the hardware i mean obviously the
hardware
hardware is where the magic is and also
on the manufacturer side so all the way
down to the
to the raw materials so going from raw
materials to the manufacturer through
the supply chain
especially when uh
the resilience of the supply chain is
tested that's engineers
all the way down it's like turtles all
the way down it's engineers all the way
down
hopefully i'm not rambling way too long
the other thing obviously
i didn't know how to ask this so of
course in my usual
mumbling way i rambled on for a while
and asking this question but
elon musk
seems and is sad to me to see but it
seems to have a non-zero
non-empty set of uh doubters
in this world and yeah you could you
could say maybe um it's because of
financial because of shorting stocks and
all those kinds of things but i know
people that don't aren't shorting the
stock and they're still
full of doubt
first of all to me as a human being that
breaks my heart i think
optimism is just fun
and also optimism is the thing that
creates the change so
but when i talked about them i think the
more interesting doubt is elon musk's
own self-doubt
and
the the doubt from people that are in
like
in the field of battle so these aren't
just critics but you know the legit
engineers that doubt whether something
is possible when there's all that kind
of doubt like you have with starship now
like you had when building autopilot
from scratch throughout the history of
autopilot what do you do
and that's when you said [ __ ] that we'll
get it done i don't care about optimism
or pessimism [ __ ] that we'll get it done
i mean i'm gonna i don't know i feel
like i'm gonna take that little clip and
just like play it every morning for
myself because you can get so lost into
overthinking stuff the reality is
just get it done and never don't quit
until it's done that's it it's simple
and the new year's resolutions uh last
thing i'll say um off mike and on mike
and afterwards we also
hung out together for new year's
i think from the company perspective
just overall first of all there's an
excitement
for the future
and uh like he tweeted today i think
let's make this the roaring 20s
i think uh
there's an optimism that coming out of
this pandemic
will build our way out of it
we will innovate our way out of it
and that means both the software and the
hardware
it's again the [ __ ] that will get it
done
and uh that's
i don't know that that optimism about
the new years uh definitely just
permeates everything so on neurolink i
mean there's a there's a lot of really
ambitious goals so on the neural net
side it's um implanting it to humans
pending fda approval all that kind of
stuff their full steam ahead there
um
tesla autopilot like you said in the
podcast uh solving level four full cell
driving
uh this year i think he said like um
like
likely this year 2022.
of course i could talk for a long time i
probably will about
each
words in that sentence like what is
level four exactly what does solve
exactly mean
and uh
what are the sort of the stages of
solution because one is the tech the
technological two is the deployment and
the human interaction so the human
factor side of it three is the policy
like is this going to get approved like
is nets are going to freak out all those
kinds of things and then social
acceptance of the technology all that
you know in interaction with vehicles
that don't have autopilot other tesla
vehicles and then other vehicles in
general so solve
is almost like uh like wittgenstein
would lose his [ __ ] over the word solve
like you know what does it exactly mean
and what does level four mean is it
under certain geographic locations and
so on but
the big point
is that in 2022 there's going to be big
leaps of improvement and that is that is
why the way i hear that message and the
full steam i had there there's so much
exciting stuff going on
most of it which is already made public
and i don't know i'm really excited as
an ai person and of course as a person
um
you know who grew up in the soviet union
will he shut up about the soviet union
already i'm sorry
i loved my dad as a physicist i loved
space exploration and to me starship and
just the number of launches that have
planned for 2022 on the spacex side uh
nasa and and everybody else is just like
pushing straight ahead into space uh
hopefully putting a human back on the
moon and hopefully
soon enough
uh let me take that 20-second pause as
well uh putting a human on mars maybe
this decade i mean to me that
that's exciting i'll go i'll be the
first human
that's why i'm training with david
goggins to be the first human on mars
and my own um
uh new year's resolutions in general i
have been working a lot on robots but i
haven't released anything yet
and this is for fun this is not for the
startup and and the business side of
things this is just i love robots i love
legged robots and i love exploring the
uh problem human robot interaction both
in research and there's almost like
philosophical art
you know in movement
there's something that robots make us
feel
and um
i want to understand that i want to
explore it together with people by
shooting a bunch of videos with robots
having robots hang out with me in in
austin in public
walking around with them uh inspire
people if people are scared to sort of
uh use that fragility to try to
understand where's the fear and try to
educate people grounded in that so i
definitely want to build a bunch of
robots
uh do a bunch of difficult interviews
they're coming up
you know i uh i do see myself as an
idiot i i i do see myself as somebody
who
relative to
how little i know
any anything that i do know even things
i spent several years on just feel so
minuscule
so i i think i just lead with humility
in these conversations
which i think can get me in trouble
but i would i would like to err on the
side of humility and love but at the
same time
there's going to be a lot of people that
criticize me often rightfully so
and i have to walk gracefully to that
fire not not not let the ego flare up to
where you start to pay uh we start to be
defensive and all those kinds of things
instead sort of calmly take the
criticism learn from the growth from it
and i've already had a few in the space
of uh coronavirus a few difficult
conversations and i'll have several more
there's some other very difficult
conversations coming up some of them in
russian so i've been also practicing
russian i'll take
if travel allows i will take a trip to
russia for maybe two or three months
take a take a journey of sorts to um
to explore the language the people the
struggles
the history
the the future
the powerful and the brilliant from the
science and the technology world
to the geopolitical world
and
also khabib
he's definitely going to be on the
podcast
but not until i wrestle him
by the way i love wrestling and there's
going to be a bunch of wrestling videos
uh coming out
uh i mean i just i love khabib so um i
love the the the dagestanis
uh uh
but vaisar said is definitely somebody i
want to talk to in russian one of the
greatest wrestlers if not the greatest
wrestlers of all time
alexander corellin
so that's a whole that's another part of
my life that i just keep to the side i
just i'm inspired by sport you know i'm
a scientist first but
sport challenges the body
to me science and philosophy challenges
the mind and i love doing both and they
both
are a source of humility i'm gonna i'm
still at mit
i will teach
i will give a bunch of lectures that
i'll teach
uh courses there
in 2022.
i really refuse to teach remotely so
there's i'll speak about this later
there's been a few challenges because of
omicron so
i may i may release a few lectures um
on video but unfortunately given how
many people signed up to the mit
lectures
it's just an insane number of people and
mit is very nervous about what's going
to happen
they might be closing their doors
harvard and stanford is going remote and
given that situation i think i would
love to
sort of um hug people with open arms
and meet them and not be so concerned
about
masks and all those kinds of things like
i would love to give the lecture when we
open back up fully and publishing papers
i want to
uh i continue doing research at mit i
have so many incredible colleagues there
so many friends so many people that
inspire me i still love mit i still love
boston most of the time i currently
though
spend
in austin
like i said
challenged myself physically mentally
we've been talking with david a lot he's
dealing with some injuries
i was dealing with some injuries but uh
we're getting close to 100 percent and
we're going to do something insane
together physically that was a
precondition i would say for a podcast i
don't want to just talk to david goggins
on a podcast you got to do something uh
crazy together first and then do a
podcast survive or die trying
uh
try okay let's see have fun like what
i'm doing here i did a podcast with tim
dillon the great the powerful one of the
greatest
living comedians tim dillon that's part
of having fun
and um doing this as part of having fun
if you guys have questions about the tim
dillon conversation i'm happy to answer
he's just so he's so awesome and
he's he's yet another way i humble
myself because he makes fun of me and i
deserve all of it
and like elon said try to be useful to
others
i think um i really don't care about
personal career success about
any kind of quote-unquote success
financial or otherwise
i think about
how can i build stuff how can i do
things that help others
it's just one it's just fun
and i
think it also directs your mind in the
proper direction
and in the end love add a bit of love to
the world
that's the uh help others you know i'm a
big fan of helping people move i like
lifting heavy things
but in the end the way i want to help
others is just by adding
uh
love to their life in whatever way i can
alright that's it for new year's
resolutions i can say a lot more but let
me just
answer a few questions i wonder if i can
just keep clicking on do these super
chats disappear i don't know what i'm
doing
i don't know what i'm doing
what what does it mean when there's
different letters before the dollar sign
are the
okay how do i
make a super chat
sticky
put wait wait i'll just read it
this is not going to work is it i'm also
slow at reading
this robot is operating at subpar
performance what's the most important
book to you or top ten a question from
joseph
yeah noni
do you agree with elon that the best way
to learn something is to talk to people
and read
i don't know
hey guys
is the
is that super chat visible
on the youtube stream
from joseph when i click on it
loading
loading i have a team of robots
all of which are superior to me nope
it's not appearing i see the no
wow the internet works no thank you all
right how do i make it appear
double click put user in time
put user in time
report add moderator no
double click
no
put user in oh timeout i don't want to
put joseph time out
all right well whatever i'm just going
to read it and we're gonna have to deal
with it
this boomers gonna have to read some
manuals tonight
um yeah my my top books i'll probably
talk about this more in the future
i'm such a sucker for animal farm i love
animal farm have read it many many many
many times it just connects to something
deep i love people that are able to
through minimum amount of words convey
something deeply honest about the human
condition about human nature whether
it's the dark side or the beautiful
aspect i love the stranger by camus
despite what
michael malus said in a recent
conversation i love the plague by camus
as well
that's very relevant to today
dostoyevsky the idiot by far my favorite
dostoevsky novel probably
i mean
probably it could be one of my favorite
novels but you know i don't usually
recommend it because maybe you're not
into memorizing 1 000 russian names and
keeping track of a bunch of weedy
narratives i just
aspire to be philosophically
uh
somebody
like the the main character which is
prince mishkin aka the idiot
the naive wage nature of his optimism is
something i aspire to and a lot of
people in the book criticize it
and uh he's the one that says beauty
will save the world and the characters
criticize that
and i think
it's unclear whether he is supposed to
whether the naivety that he has is
supposed to be positive or negative and
and that's the struggle of the book and
to me i would err on the side of the of
that of of the naive
uh
positivity appreciation of beauty um
longing
for uh for love
i agree with elon very much that reading
is like a superpower so talking to
people
so talk to the experts
uh just like i've talked to jim keller a
bunch of times and every time i talk to
him i've learned like 10x than i would
ever learn about it
in any other way i would say in in the
specific things we talk about so
engineering discussions with experts is
just uh incredible
are you a robot
would you take no for an answer
and for me reading definitely
definitely is is like it's like a
shortcut to learning so i'm a huge
believer in reading it's there's there's
so many different paths and trajectories
you can take through the reading space
you can you can learn about uh human
nature through reading history
you can uh read like business books
which you know some of them are full of
cliches and so on even like advice books
but
it's still when you cut through all the
[ __ ] there there's like kernels of
advice that can shake up your mind and
truly
help you
[Music]
truly help you
discover yourself sorry i get a little
bit distracted every once in a while
there's also just technical books uh or
like
uh popular versions of uh technical
books like something by sean carroll or
even sapiens
like looking at evolutionary biology
view of life or anything by richard
dawkins those kinds of things make you
give you another perspective on
on humanity
and somehow that kind of uh percolates
down to um
to your own life as well
lex maybe you can turn on the slow chat
mode that's one of the folks from our
team i don't even know how to do that
man
i'm barely hanging on here and i'm
scared i'm still scared shitless okay
favorite favorite book i don't know i
keep changing i would say the idiot
number one animal farm number two
uh
right uh so
yeah let me quick click on super chats
you know what i'm just gonna uh trust
trust my team of uh incredible folks i
don't know if they want me to call them
out by name
one of them is russian and has a strong
russian accent i can't i'm not going to
do a russian accent
so sorry they're paying attention to the
super chats they'll grab them
uh
i'm getting some russian emojis from
them all right cool
uh
lessons from elon
matt
efrontie asks love all the work lex keep
crushing it brother thank you man what
is the biggest lessons you've learned
through talking with elon musk
as i take a 20-second silent pause
i apologize i'm thinking
in in many ways
don't listen
to anybody
when it
contradicts
the
the careful rigorous first principles
conclusions of your mind
so your parents
society
friends
loved ones
school
don't listen to anybody
they have learned the ways of the past
if you want to define the future
you have to think on your own and take
big risks with
the thoughts you take
so i just
it's not necessarily like a lesson i
learned from him through words but
through actions
just the way we talk about anything he
refuses to be weighed down by the way
things were done in the past
and that's a superpower
listen to no one when it takes uh when
it comes to following
like some kind of hunger to create the
new thing that you have and that
but i should say it's not just about
listening to
the the person it's really spending time
in that space around them and i think
that speaks to the fact that you should
really surround yourself by people
who refuse to be weighed down
by
the momentum of the way things are done
about the expectations and limitations
and constraints of society
okay
um
elon's flaws don't touch me i'm crazy
says
i love the internet and your username
dear sir madam
do you believe elon has flaws as an
individual aside from his career
accomplishments
flaws
of course of course he has flaws he has
many flaws that's what makes us human
it's the uh
robin williams from um good will hunting
right
that speech he makes about his um
about himself and his wife
that they're flawed he tells that story
about her um
farting in the night and she wakes
herself up
and i think that was improvised actually
and that that whole story just shows
that's the good stuff i think that's
what he says that's the good stuff
that's what
makes us who we are that's what we fall
in love with that's what um
that that's the kind of perturbation
that results in progress if you're
perfect things perfect people don't make
progress
[ __ ] up people make progress
it's the the whole kerouac thing it's
them the mad ones the ones from me are
the mad ones
um yeah i can list a bunch of flaws
the the very thing i said that's the
great advice the flaw of being
of being unwilling to fit in which makes
them difficult to talk to because uh is
constantly challenging
the
the small talk of our
daily existence
love of course i talk about love so much
and
and he's so focused on engineering
problems
that
sometimes that um like i asked him
in in several ways i tried to ask him
about love romantic love
friendship and family
and you could tell how uncomfortable he
was with that
he said now that is a truly peculiar
question i think is what he said
and then he went on to uh quote uh what
is love baby don't hurt me
right so
i think
i don't know if it's a flaw to me it's a
flaw because uh
um
allowing yourself to be fragile
to
um
to the ups and downs of attachment to
others to love
i think is truly fulfilling and makes
you a better engineer and better
entrepreneur the problem is when you
feel the world heavily when you feel
the the
the connection to others when that's
ultimately is lost or is damaged or is
hurt
again the ups and downs of love
that's going to really hurt
and that pain is not productive in terms
of launching rockets to space so i think
one of the things that elon is better
than anybody i've ever met
is whenever there's tragic events
whenever there's difficult events
whenever there's emergencies
he's able to think clearly and say okay
well this happened what is the right
next step to take to solve this problem
it's not like
meandering about the negativity around
uh why did this happen in terms of like
the unproductive why it's the
like why did bad you know things happen
to good people that kind of stuff nope
this happened that's the way it is what
is the best thing we could do let's make
that action
i can continue but let's leave it there
ultramarathons plans on competing
any
sorry just so many questions uh plans on
competing in any ultra marathons i i
don't
uh perhaps but i really hate running
that's why i love running is i hate
running
it tests my mind i get on the road and
like one mile in
all the demons i have
why how aren't having you
done this and that and all the things
that you you said you're going to do you
told yourself you're going to do you
haven't done it yet why are you still
single why are you why is your like uh
where are the robots you love robots
like let's let's get them uh running
around austin all the productivity
questions all that is just
you know what are you doing with your
life and then the questions of mortality
all that comes out like one mile in if
we're being honest it's like a half a
mile in and so that process that's why i
love
uh
i'm pooping lex congratulations sir or
madam i congratulate you i hope it goes
well for you
uh that's why i both love and hate
running and so for me like the race
itself is not important the
ultramarathon race but david goggins
whatever we do whether it's on road
i don't i don't want to do a treadmill
thing with him i just love nature so i
want to go out outside
whatever whatever we do i think i can
break them
or break myself in the process
well when i was out in vegas doing
push-ups with him
i think i legitimately thought i could
do more push-ups in my
drunk madness than david goggins so i'm
excited for the possibility of facing
him and running not not really a
competition with david of course it's a
competition with myself and seeing how
far i can go the longest i've ever run
is 22 miles in one take i've done the
4x4 by 48 but in one take is 22 miles
and that actually had to quit because uh
i didn't get enough salt and water it
just i started shivering
and uh
yeah i want to see how far i can go
how much pain i can take so definitely
will happen this year and we'll do a
podcast before and after
uh i so hey lex if you want to turn on
slow mode just go to settings live chat
toggle on
slow mode
i thought me speaking slowly
is already activating slow mode
you get it
i don't know where the settings button
is bro
okay let's just leave it at this we'll
do slow mode next time if that's a
beneficial thing
all right
david fravor
leah asks
you're amazing lex love you love you too
thanks for this interview in interview
number four
are you going to
number four are you going to
talk about david fravor's ufos
thanks for the 42 question
i am puzzled by you and your question
lina 27
but anyway i will talk about ufos a
bunch more i just want to you know i i
honestly want to talk to bob lazar i
haven't really reached out and he was
interested
i i like the human side of things too
it's like it's a thing i'm interested
with alex jones too
is not so much the conspiracy theories
and all those kinds of things it's
how does this affect your mind
having these ideas in your head how does
it affect your mind
how are you able to still have
compassion for other human beings still
have an inkling of optimism about the
world and the same with bob lazar
you know
david fravor probably will talk again
alex i forgot her name i apologize i'm
so bad with names but uh she's a she's
another pilot that saw what david saw
she's huge i'll definitely do a podcast
with her
and uh
in general i just uh
right
in general i just loved obviously i love
ufos
so it inspires me i don't think
um a lot of people have a conversation
about it like it's a cynical thing about
government
but for me i love ufos because it
inspires me of the possibilities of both
the intelligent life that's out there
all the possible things we can
understand about ourselves and about the
world and about the universe from
interacting with them for searching for
them for trying to communicate with them
and then very practical engineering
aspects of just knowing that something
is possible
it would allow us to engineer propulsion
systems that could move much faster
uh so on on this topic lex xylix asks
are there so many x's in this
zaleks asks lex do you think elon has
witnessed any high forms of technology
he cannot publicly
and it's describe possible that i know
the answer to this question
but if i told you
xylix i would have to kill you
um
let me take a sip of this before i read
a question about jordan peterson
um
big fan of caffeine caffeine all the way
the one drug
i uh i truly truly appreciate and
partake in
vodka every once in a while caffeine
every day
uh
okay jordan peterson scott mcblaine asks
hey lex smiley face will you ever have
jordan peterson on the podcast thanks
for all your work
you make my life better thank you
brother thank you scott yeah we
definitely have uh i've talked to jordan
offline
a bunch of times we'll definitely do a
podcast together and i think it'll be
epic there's no rush
i think
my concern with jordan always is
to make sure that he's healthy happy and
just like all people and he's he's had a
difficult year and
i don't know i like who cares about
podcasts like well-being health
is more important than anything else and
i think he has a
like a
heck of a crazy tour coming up this year
i actually have tickets to see him i'm
sure he'll do a few podcasts but you
know with a tour like that
i wish him godspeed and the best of luck
and just stay healthy stay focused
uh stay optimistic and just i mean he
could do so
much good
in this world by thinking through the
problems of the world and walking again
gracefully through the fire and i wish
him the best of luck i think we'll have
a conversation unlike the others he's
had i think i'd like to have a very long
one with him three four hours probably
several times in our lives
one i wanted to be a psychiatrist i'm
fascinated by the psychology side of
things so a real psychology conversation
carl young
i have trouble speaking
um
so on the psychology side
from freud to young and all those kinds
of things to the philosopher's side to
the
to the communist question of uh gulags
and soldiers into stalin
to hitler
it's like history human nature human
condition discussion i'm not interested
in identity politics of the day i'm
not interested in that bickering it
let other people are much better than me
at this
and at most things but this certainly
and um
walkism all those kinds of things i'm
not
i
i think those are the battles of the day
that will pass and what will remain are
the same lessons of history that we can
learn today by thinking about history
and to me
with jordan peterson the interesting
discussion is about communism
about what went wrong why
what can go wrong again
also the interesting tension is between
the the man's search for meaning because
for him
that journey that search
uh
in part goes through religious
thought religious exploration and that's
really interesting
because um
i don't even know what religion and
spirituality means it's such a beautiful
space
and i never liked sort of hardcore
atheism or obviously hardcore
religious
um thought
but there's something in the middle
there and that gray area in that fog of
where many people find meaning there's a
lot to be discovered and i i love the
the conversation he had with sam harris
about the topic the tension through the
tension over that discussion you could
discover something new together and
that's actually the best of
conversations
uh
jordan15396
ah that jordan
asks
what would you do with a week left to
live
i meditate on death a lot so i often
think i'm going to die today i enjoyed
that
you know i'm truly happy that
this live stream i could do
with uh
today
and die right after i'm happy i can
genuinely say
that
i prefer to not die mid-sentence
uh like people can quote me on the last
thing i said in the last stream like i
hope that live stream wasn't me quoting
the person that was pooping
and complimenting on them
uh
but other than that i i just every day i
contemplate if this is the last day of
my life am i happy and the answer to
that has been
unequivocally yes for the longest time
so
with a week left to live
i would probably spend it in silence
with the people i love
i would also spend it thinking
because unlike the
thought experiment of dying today
uh
unlike the thought experiment of dying
today this is reality so it's going to
hit even harder and i want to see what
are the thoughts sort of introspect
what are the thoughts possibly with the
help of psychedelics that would be
interesting actually dmt definitely
pretty girl elon musk says pretty girl
fake elon musk says pretty girl
um
girl on the
uh hood of a cadillac yeah that's uh
that's the office song
um free love freeway i guess you guys
should check it out it's the most
ridiculous song
i i definitely you know probably with a
pretty girl i love hopefully i would be
in a relationship at that point
but if i die today
there's plenty of people i love in my
life i would spend time with them
sergey who's on the team he's the
russian guy
says the right answer is edit the
[ __ ] podcast that's right sergey edit
the podcast is what you would do when
there's only one week left
that's called dedication i love you
brother okay uh
oh yeah i'll wrap up soon um
so
i had a few questions about tim dillon
uh let me let me say i think there's a
podcast coming out with tim dillon on um
the tim dillon show
on monday so he said he came down to my
place we recorded a conversation
together
and i'm a huge fan of his i did a
podcast he was on on the on this on the
lex whatever podcast that i do i really
enjoyed that
i think
the reason i wanted to do a conversation
with him so first of all he's a friend
he's somebody who inspires me i disagree
with him obviously on a lot of things
but
he
masterfully puts my and ego in check and
the ego of uh
a ton of people
the powerful
um
and that's really important and to do it
with grace with uh with mastery of
comedy is it's just it's really good i i
in general
like like i said on the podcast smart
people that act silly versus silly
people that act smart and um
again i don't know
if i'm smart but i will always err on
the side of the silly and to me
just being silly
not taking myself seriously not ever
taking myself seriously being able to
take a joke is essential for um
to see clearly through the fog
of
all the uncertainty that is around us
it's so easy to delude yourself to think
you really understand things
that you can see the truth i you have to
have humility that you will never be in
possession of the truth you can only get
closer and closer and that humility to
me is an essential element of that so
the moment you start taking yourself
seriously you start liking the sound of
your own voice as i say on a
on a freaking uh live stream
the moment you start to fall in love
with yourself in a way that just deludes
you is
the moment you become arrogant and are
no longer to be able to discover the
truth again tim dillon is essential for
that he uh
i mean he was pretty he's pretty rough
on me in a few spots i'm sure people are
gonna
make fun of me of the silly things i
said on there but i deserve it all i
will always deserve it and uh
bring it on internet that's why i love
the internet
whole truth to power
and um
i will always err on the side of silly
in fact one of the things that i've been
able to do
more and more lately and one of the
things that elon inspires me to do is be
silly don't take yourself or the world
seriously laugh
laugh at the whole thing at the whole
absurdity of it it'll be over before you
know it
[ __ ] it's going to be over before you
know it
who's your favorite comedian
am johnson asks who is your favorite
comedian
yeah
sergey says
it's on topic
um
i have so many obviously you don't want
to pick
each one
has uh
i just love comedy there's so many
amazing it's really unfair so i can pick
a favorite book i can pick a favorite
song even
be tough but i could do it with
comedians i really it's very difficult
so obviously since i'm appearing on tim
dillon's show he is by far the greatest
comedian of all time
the great so we're really saying who is
the number two
because by far tim dillon is the
greatest comedian of all time
and the most valuable person of all time
is ben his producer tim dillon does zero
work contributes nothing to the show
really the most important person
ever arguably so you have gandhi and so
on but above that is ben the producer
for the tim dylan show
aside from that obviously joe rogan has
been a huge inspiration to me in a
million ways and i've talked about it
endlessly
uh mitch hedberg
in terms of one-liners
just
[ __ ] genius just
just and we lose him too early
i'm gonna get emotional here um
louis ck just like
um
the dark humor of louis ck unparalleled
like i just uh
just i mean it reminds me of the russian
humor it's it's the darkness but done so
masterfully that it brings out like
somehow an optimism
um
the mark norman is actually an example
of somebody like that i i we just had a
podcast together he's he's got that
mitch hedberg
vibe but he goes even darker which i
love
um
yeah and i think uh norm mcdonald
somebody um
so there's like stand-up comedy and
there's
what those stand-up comics do outside of
that because you can't just take it in
one like norman mcdonald's just a genius
the
somebody actually made a comment about
the michael malus conversation about
norman donald maybe i can try to find
the quote he tweeted this in 2018
um
god damn it like
just the the grace with which he left
this world telling no one
the genius
anyway he tweeted uh
the idiot sees the world as good versus
evil the cynic sees the world as evil
versus evil the truth that no one seems
able to see is that the world is and
always has been a battle of good
versus good
norm mcdonald ladies and gentlemen
so the brilliance of that statement is
that
i mean you know the idiot is a word i
like because i i think it fills me with
humility so setting that aside but
the
we often frame things you know when we
beat the drums of war it's good versus
evil we're the good guys that we have to
fight the words of the evil
uh the actions of the evil the the nazis
the the terrorists
uh whatever can go on and and those
drums of war beating now
with
with russia with china
and um again i think we should lead with
humility and compassion first
even in the face of atrocities
anyway
the cynic
just gives up and seeing is basically
the powerful the evil versus evil the
power sentence of the world battling
each other but i think norm is is
absolutely correct that it is good
versus good because
the the truth behind that statement is
that
each of the individual
centers of power and the leaders think
that they're doing the good the right
thing for the world hitler thought he
was doing the good the right thing for
the world stalin thought he was doing
the good the right thing for the world
we americans when we go to war think
we're doing the right thing
israel-palestine conflict
both sides think they're doing the good
thing for the world
it's good versus good
and all the atrocities of the world
i think
have been committed in part
as a battle of good versus good and
that's the tragic the difficult aspect
that we have to uh acknowledge about
human nature
is that all of us think we're the good
guys and we're doing the good thing
but
we have to have the humility
to question is it are we truly doing the
good thing
all right maybe a couple more questions
and i'll uh cut it off in an hour and
we'll do this again another time would
you get drunk with elon how do you know
hasn't already happened
a conversation with historical figure
uh mkhada7 asks if elon could talk to
one person in the past for one hour
who would that person be the same goes
for eulex
so by the way i i don't know how to do
this live stream thing and i'm sure elon
and folks like that would join
live streams like these for a few
minutes i don't i don't want to take up
a long time that's that's better for a
long form podcast but it would be fun to
have elon roll in for like 5-10 minutes
just to do some fun stuff so
elon
joe rogan
tim dillon even i love that idea just
roll in michael malus like literally he
lives close to me he could he could be
under the table right now
and you wouldn't know
um
so i definitely want to do that in the
future i just have to figure out how to
pull how to bring in guests i barely
know what i'm doing with this live
stream so
anyway if you want if elon could talk to
one person in the past for one hour who
would that person be the same goes for
your legs so he actually answered this
similar question
on a recent podcast he had uh we talked
about this also offline
i think for him it's
you know albert einstein isaac newton
all those kinds of uh
almost
engineering people i
i get it i get it like for me in that
vein would be like alan touring probably
i just
there's so little content
from him
uh like relatively speaking that i would
like to talk to alan turing for an hour
but then again an hour is not enough
it's got to be a weekend because we
gotta get drunk richard feynman is a
good example somebody i would really
enjoy the hell out of that hour but i
wouldn't get new information it would
just be fun
so is it about having fun or is it about
getting new information
uh are you single lex yes i am
unfortunately uh nikola tesla no i would
err on the side of evil
that's gonna be a clip and taken out of
context i would talk to somebody
that
i would probably talk to hitler i would
probably talk to hitler
so the problem is that it's the german
thing so i'm if we have to if he somehow
magically could speak english or russian
because i don't speak german so it'd be
lost in translation
and
so then
stalin
stalin in
early when lenin was still alive maybe
doing a room together with len and
stalin to understand
what is what is in the mind of the
people that led to the suffering the
death of tens of millions and the
suffering of hundreds of millions
what is this
because i feel like if i talk to them
and take it back to the present time
the the lessons will reverberate in a
way that i'll be able to help prevent it
in a way that i can't just by reading
their works
i feel like stuff from einstein all
those kinds of things are captured
within their written work
some of these impactful leaders
that
cause suffering in the world
i think
most of their evil
is not put down on paper
chairman mao yeah genghis khan sure all
those are interesting but richard
feynman alan turing richard feynman alan
turing
just because i can update them on the
whole
neural networks look oh okay
richard feynman alan turing
and einstein
in a tesla
plaid
with
fsd autopilot
flooring it i want to see the look on
touring's face
all of their faith but touring's face
this is neural networks this is ai
[ __ ]
uh he would be proud although he thought
we're gonna solve intelligence by year
2000 anyway he'd be kind of impressed by
the whole thing
and einstein would be disappointed
you know what if einstein's in the car
i'm also going to stop by in that tesla
plaid
and uh pick up eric weinstein on the way
i want to i want to have those two have
a conversation
i feel like they'd figure something out
like why haven't we come up with a
theory of everything yet
and make it a podcast alright this is
getting way too excited
final question
let's see what should we make the final
question
would you talk to jesus yes
um jesus
let's say
all right
maybe one more question before the final
question oh yeah i see a good final
question right
uh so non-final question second to last
question from paulo taraw
who would you want most to have on your
podcast in 2022
so
i think the names like like putin elon
again
barack obama
donald trump
these are all people that fascinate me
i would also love to talk to the
chairman the president of china
there's a lot of people i would like to
talk to of that level
yes girl pearlman and so on
but i think
who i want
to be on the podcast it takes it back to
that uh
person i talked to um
that kind of it's
uh
i think it was on uh memorial day i had
a conversation with a guy he said he was
a fan he's wearing like american flags
everywhere and you're saying you know
i'm a fan of the podcast
i listen to you i listen to joe
and um
you know you guys talk to some of the
most brilliant people some of the
funniest people and just these like
celebrities and so on like why don't you
ever talk to us regular folk us regular
folk
and uh
yeah
uh that stuck with me i'd like to talk
to uh
quote unquote regular folk
what uh what what tim dillon made fun of
me for saying i think i'm a simple
man
i'd like to talk to other simple men and
women
um because they're not that simple and
they're not they're not regular folk
they're not less special
they're they're as special
and uh they have a story
and i want to learn about those stories
so that's what i want to do more in
2022.
final question
from andre
all right we'll do this again i'm really
really sorry i don't know what the heck
i'm doing i had this idea real quick
before i read the final question of uh
i i love skyrim okay i love video games
in general i don't get a chance to play
them but i love skyrim and i had to
i saw somebody was had this video where
they just walk around skyrim
just like
for a couple hours just enjoying nature
i would love that
i would um
just walk around maybe answer some
questions but just the calmness of that
i just i feel
that fits
that just that's a place where i could
be happy in the digital space of skyrim
just to take a little stroll in the
woods
a walk in the woods by bill bryson
oh and uh another person you know who
i'd really want to have on the podcast
this comes back
okay i'll put it out there so definitely
people with great stories but not
celebrities just regular folk
but if there is one quote unquote
celebrity i would love to talk to
not alex jones uh alex
love alex send him all my love
maybe one day we'll see
i would say satoshi nakamoto
yeah satoshi yes magnus carlos and all
those people i would love to figure out
i would love to
somehow definitively
at least i know that i'm talking to him
or her or them
somehow i would know for sure
and maybe would have to be blurred out
all those kinds of things i would love
to
to pierce the veil of anonymity
at least for me to peek behind the
curtain
for no reason i would tell nobody i
would take that to my death but i'd out
i don't know how that's possible but i'm
going to put that out there okay
as a thing that i would love to do
there's something i just deeply
appreciate about
the humility and the power of anonymity
of releasing a technology that can
change the world and still not putting
your name publicly behind it
yeah it's like banksy
um
yeah i would love to talk to him anyway
last question from andre
that'd be funny if it was andre kopathi
are we living in a simulation
it's a good question
the answer is yes
and it's
powered
by love
i love you all this is really fun i hope
to do it again soon thank you so much